foreign
[Music]
good morning everyone
my name is Teresa Ridgeway and I'm a
technical program manager at Google as
well as the children's book author of
think like a computer
today I'll be sharing with you a little
bit about the story behind my story
and everything in between As Told by my
favorite musical artist Beyonce
one of the first things that I learned
at a very early age was stepping into my
superpower
at the time my as if my mother was up
here and speaking with you she would let
you know that Dada was probably my
second my second word my first word of
course would have been why
why I wanted to know why about
everything I enjoyed learning at a very
early age which as you could imagine was
a very very interesting childhood
especially for a patient mother
so as a kid I stepped into that
superpower and understanding you know
why things work the way that they do and
one of the very first lessons that I
could remember is receiving a computer
for the first time and literally my
mother just dropped it on the kitchen
counter and let me figure it out she was
like I got it from my classroom here
have at it so I did everything from
plugging it up to turning it on and with
that lesson I learned like I started
questioning why like if I press the
letter k on the keyboard how does the
computer know to display it on the
screen
so with that it just kind of triggered
all these different thoughts and turned
me into the problem solver I am today
but one of the other very important
lessons that I learned was also
resonance and perseverance and those
things fit me well for the remainder of
my life
the next chapter I would kind of skip a
little bit into the covet pandemic as
much of the speakers here have done
because I feel that it was a very
life-changing part for all of us so as
the world was starting to shut down for
the pandemic I shut down maybe a few
months prior due to the passing of both
my mother my brother-in-law and my
sister
and with having the immense grief of
dealing with all of those deaths back to
back it actually gave me a time to
retrospectively look while everything
was quiet and figure out what I wanted
to do with my life going forward
but even with those deaths I didn't let
it break my soul instead I chose to let
those lessons and the the big shoes that
they left to be filled to inspire my
journey and what I would like my legacy
to be so I'd like to share with you a
little bit about my children's book that
came about during the pandemic and
during the time that I was you know in
my immense grief I decided to
talk about my childhood love of
computers to introduce other children to
computers as well and I wrote the book
series and the first book in the book
series is called think like a computer
which follows a young girl seven years
old getting her computer for the first
time for her birthday and trying to
figure out what to do with it and
knowing that she has to think like a
computer to get it to talk to her
so I'm sharing here a few of the
different images because within the book
not only do I talk about my journey of
computers and problem solving and things
like that but I really tie into a lot of
the family aspects of me my middle
sister and my oldest sister and my mom
and my dad all being helpful and loving
and triggering a lot of those different
thoughts
foreign
addition to that I'm going to also share
with you a few of the different things
that have happened because of this so
when my sister passed I was right in the
middle of lead so I took some time off
and during my time back as life would
have it I took the power course as my
first course coming back I changed
course instead of focusing on my career
but to focus more on my legacy and my
think like a computer book
and with the power class I had to step
into a lot of things as you may can tell
I'm shaking in my boots right now
speaking with you because I'm an
introvert at heart but what the power
class told me to do is to kind of just
step into my power and that's what I did
I literally created objectives every
week of how will I get more kids to be
interested in computer science and how
can I get that messaging out and with
that within the the time in the class I
was able to book my local targets to do
story times get my books in the stores I
was featured in Forbes Magazine I've
been traveling around the world on some
of the pictures you may see here I was
invited to Harlem in New York City to
speak with a coding group of young girls
that are interested in computer science
I was able to speak to different
classrooms and just really get the
messaging out and share my story with
kids so this is definitely a different
crowd than I usually talk to it's
usually second graders
yeah
um and then I shared a little bit about
the background of the picture so they
Illustrated that a lot of soul searching
and pulling out all the different things
that I wanted to express visually in the
book so I shared with her pictures of my
family growing up as you can see here
I'm in a yellow dress my favorite dress
you'll probably see it a few more times
and to really capture that essence of me
being an inquisitive young girl a Little
Bit Sassy into the character that you
see in the book
you'll also see both my parents who were
my favorite illustrations in the book my
dad was a basketball coach and looked
exactly like the character and it's
probably my favorite and my supportive
mother who gave me the computer and
introduced me to computers and just let
me figure it out
my two older sisters and me in the
yellow dress of course my middle sister
went off to be a rocket scientist and my
oldest sister that passed during the
pandemic was an English teacher so I
talked a lot about her introductions
into English and things that she liked
and actually her helping me during the
pandemic prior to her passing helping me
edit the book
so she's she's always been that great
supportive system for me and then I also
spent a lot of time talking about my
second grade teacher who introduced me
to math and science and created the love
that I have that I that I share with the
world today
and then of course from a family aspect
my cousins I wanted that to be a very
important part of the book because I
feel family is is very very important to
me and it has been a very big part of my
upbringing so I wanted to ensure that I
shared that in the story so that it
relates to more kids as well
and then of course because I had a lot
of time during the pandemic I just kept
writing and then I'm turning the book
into a book series and as of this week
the second book in this series is out
and it's called to the moon it's a story
about me going to the science fair and
using my sister's help to teach me how
to code in Python to create a Rover that
travels on the moon I like to say we're
going to going to the moon in the book
but it's actually a science fair project
and then before I let you go I just
wanted to share that not only are my
lessons in power
that were so beneficial to me but one
word of encouragement if anyone relates
to the story or being an introvert and
you know just pushing yourself beyond
the limits one of the things that I I
feel like I had to do is standing in
your power can look a lot like shaking
in your boots but what you have to do is
just go out there and do it and force
yourself to do it so that would be my
recommendation and my words of
encouragement to you thank you so much
[Music]